okay so in this module we are going to
be talking about the resolution for
first order logic this is an optional
module but i think it would be
interesting to think about how we could
apply a resolution when we have this
more complicated logic dispersed order
logic and so far we have talked about
syntax semantics we have talked about
modus ponens when we have foreign
clauses in first order logic and now we
want to extend this the idea of applying
inference rules to settings where we
don't necessarily have horn clauses so
if you think about first order logic
it's not really limited to settings
where we have horn clauses we sometimes
have non-horn clauses here's actually an
example for all x axis student this
implies x no sum y okay so so the sum y
is there exists y here is is is going to
create a non-horn clause and why is that
because an existential quantifier is
really a glorified or right like it's a
glorified disjunction so so what this is
basically getting us is knows x and and
y one or x y y two and so on and and and
this basically creates an or on this
side of the implication and that makes
this particular statement a non-haram
clause okay
so what does that mean that means that i
can't just apply modus ponens on it okay
so so what can we do here so the high
level strategy here is that we have this
formula we have this first order logic
formula first off you need to convert it
to a cnf form form to a conjunctive
normal form and this is similar to
before like before even in propositional
logic when we had something that wasn't
a horn clause we were starting with
writing it as a cnf form okay and then
after that we repeatedly apply
resolution rule on it and our resolution
rule here is going to be slightly
different from the resolution rule that
we had in propositional logic because
similar to modus ponens we need to do
unification we need to do substitution
and then and similarly we change our
resolution rule to actually have that
element of unification and substitution
here okay
converting to cnf is also not exactly
like we did converting to cnf in
propositional logic there are going to
be a few new things that i'm going to
attempt to give you some ideas around it
but in general i'm just giving like a
high level strategy idea of how you're
going to apply resolution to first order
logic this is not a very complete um
complete explanation of that and in
general it gets a little bit messy like
when you think about applying resolution
to first order logic so think of this as
a big picture like high level strategy
and overview
for applying resolution here okay
all right so so let's start with a
formula let's say this is our formula
and we have for all x for all y and y is
an animal implies x loves y and that
implies that uh there exists and y uh so
such that y loves x okay so so this is
some some statement some formula and and
what we like to do is we would like to
convert this to a cnf form so how does a
cnf form look like in first order logic
so at the end of the day the output is
going to look something like this for us
so it's going to be an end of a bunch of
clauses so these are clauses because
they have orders between them
and in addition to that we have these
new functions this capitalized y or
capitalized c and these are called
scollon functions and i'm going to talk
about what they are in in a few slides
okay
so there are a few things that are new
when we think about the cnf form the
first thing is that all variables that i
have in this form are actually like
universally quantified so there is like
a for all x that exists here that i've
just dropped okay so so in reality there
is a for all x that exists here
and then there are these column
functions that are functions of of
things that are existentially uh
quantified right so so basically
basically they represent existential
quantifiers here and and they're
functions of this x thing that that has
a for all x at the beginning on it okay
so those are kind of like two new things
that are happening uh in order to get a
cnf form of this first order logic
formula let's actually go through an
example for this so let's start with
this statement that says anyone who
likes all animals is liked by someone
okay so one can write this as an input
that says for all x for all y y is an
animal implies x y and that whole thing
implies that uh there exists in y so
y loves x okay
all right so uh first thing to do is
similar to before if you want to
like follow like the steps of converting
the stone cnf form we're going to
eliminate implications so i'm going to
eliminate this outside implement
implication how do i eliminate eliminate
it i'm going to take the negation of
what comes before it so negation up
until here
or
the rest of the statement
i'm also going to replace this
implication by negation of the first
part or the second part so negation of
the first part or the second part
and we get this this statement okay
now i'm going to push negations inwards
and eliminate double negations this is
exactly what we have done before so let
me push negations inside and it goes all
the way to negation of love and and now
we have ended up with this formula where
we have these quantifiers right like we
have this for all under exist and so on
and everything else is an atomic formula
right remember before like when you are
trying to convert things to a cnn form
we would end up with prepositional with
prepositional symbols right so we would
have you'd end up with propositional
symbols that that could take a positive
or negative negative value right so we
would have positive or negative literals
at the end of the day but here we have
atomic formulas so so we end up with
these atomic formulas are negations of
these atomic formulas okay
so now one thing that is new is we're
kind of standardizing the variables here
so so we have a y here and we have a y
here but but there is this existential
quantifier on each of them and these y's
are kind of treated as as a local
variable so so in order to kind of like
avoid confusions you're going to define
like a new variable for each of them so
i'm going to define a z here and keep
this as y and again the reason i'm doing
this is at the end of the day i'm
removing this for all x and i want to
make sure that these this y is a
function of x and this z is a function
of x and these are different things
these are two different local variables
okay
all right so so this is new so i'm
standardizing variables this is a new
step that is done here okay
now now that we are left with this
formula what we're going to do is we're
going to replace all these existential
existentially quantified variables with
something that's called the skollon
function okay so so we before we had
there exists a y and and this there
exists of y it depends on x2 right so
for all x there existed by so this is
really a function of x the skollen
function the y function of x
this column function is y function of x
or z is a function of x so i'm going to
write these column functions as
functions of this variable that is that
is universally quantified and then i'm
going to just drop that i'm going to
later on drop this for all x so that
that makes my life easier
and then finally i need to distribute
or over end so i can end up with clauses
and conjunctive normal form and this is
a similar step that we've had before in
propositional logic and remove the
universal quantifiers and this is what i
would end up at so so now i've end up in
in with the formula in cnf form uh in
first order logic
okay so just just recap what is new in
it we have scollon functions which kind
of represent existential quantifiers and
variables that are universally
quantified i've also dropped the
universal quantifier a universal
quantifier on all my variables here okay
so that those are kind of like the core
differences here okay so now we are
ready to talk about resolution now that
we can write our formulas our first
audiologic formulas in cnf form then we
can write the resolution rule as follows
so we have these atomic formulas f1 or
through fn or p and then we have another
thing in our set of premises negation of
q or g one through g m
and and notice that p and q could be
different things because they might just
look different from each other so what
we do is we unify p and q and when we
unify p and q we get a substitution rule
theta and and then what we can actually
infer what we can derive here from
resolution is going to be an or of f1 or
all the way through fn or g1 all the way
through gn we are basically cancelling
out p and q with each other but the
reason we can do that is we have unified
p and q is with the substitution rule
theta so so in this new formula we are
substituting theta in the formula
and this is kind of similar to the
substitution and unification that we did
in
modus ponens we're just doing this now
on resolution on these uh cnf clauses
that that we have we have just created
okay
let's look at an example here so so
let's say that i have two cnf clauses
and here so i have animal y of x or
love z of x x and then i have negation
of loves u and v or feats u and v okay
so loves and negation of loves are the
things that i would like to i would like
to be able to do uh unification on so if
i unify these two then i'm gonna come up
with a substitution rule that says
substitute variable u with function c of
x substitute uh the variable v with with
variable x okay and at the end of the
day the thing that i'm invariant i'm
deriving here is going to basically
cancel out these two and it's going to
get animal y of x
or
feet u and v but i'm not going to put u
and v in there anymore why why why is
that because i'm substituting this theta
i'm substituting
z of x for u and x for b so so the thing
that at the end of the day i'm improving
is animal y event of i of x or v to z of
x x okay so this is there's quite a bit
of like symbol manipulation going on
here but kind of like get the gist of it
it's very similar to resolution that we
have seen so far combined with
unification and substitution over these
new new causes in these new cnf clauses
that we have talked about and that
summarizes how we do inference uh using
resolution in first order logic